hey I understand I mean everybody's you
know approach to quarantine is is
different it's all relative and
everybody's life
but I understand your approach to
quarantine was less toilet paper and
more booze is that right I couldn't
believe it
like on day one of lockdown everywhere
in the world people go to supermarkets
and stockpiling toy are fighting over
toilet rolls how many I just thought
that was I would give up my last toilet
roll to a glass of beer I'd rather be
drunk then we're the same person
I thought it was crazy the toilet paper
crisis of 2020 I was like what about
food I mean those people to spite you on
day were there justice or people to if
there was a plane crash they start
eating their sandwiches well something I
love that you've done in quarantine did
you create is there a badminton court in
your house yes yes we thought we've got
garden and then we found one of those
cupboards that you do like for 10 years
we put it up then we ordered some spray
chalk from Amazon and we put out the
markings and then we played every day
yeah so that's that's really been like
so like far-fetched of a sport and I'm
getting to the age now where I make a
noise when I bend over enough to stand
up that so
do that too I'm 38 whatever subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going